it's not delusional optimism it's tragic
optimism either everything is great
always or everything sucks this that
everything is just terrible if you are
Pana about everything and you bury your
head in the sand well then you don't
have to do anything everything's perfect
whereas the despair porn and everything
sucks always people it's like an
intellectual version of toxic positivity
and everything's hopeless anyways so
like I don't have to do anything in
between toxic positivity and despair is
like the ability to have some hope and
to take action and and ideally to take
meaningful action we have to trudge
forward with as much of a positive
attitude as we can